hey guys I'm Tiffany Smith I'm Kristian
harloff and we are at the fernando space
and we're here with Justin Timberlake
Anna Kendrick from their animated
musical such a good introduction so
yourself I was really excited I had that
host energy that was there so good I
wasn't worried like I was that mom based
I'm like what the hell I know I was
trying to build up and I guess we stole
our intro you wanted to introduce
yourselves no it's doing Alistar oh my
god
all right now Justin Timberlake Anna
Kendrick from trolls [ __ ] roles
you're there that's her that's what this
bar setup makes you feel like you like
sometimes walked in and you're like hey
let's hang out yeah
I need like a glass to you know tell me
you have had a long day like you got the
Hat you gonna put the Hat on a little
what what's the Hat the Hat yes yeah
yeah yeah I'm here
pleasure seeing you here is way more
flavor life well we are very excited to
have here I'll tell you what she's great
you're super excited well are there
nothing funny cuz I got to see the clips
revised are by the way where is that art
yeah do we know no I chose wisely never
tell um okay so we were very excited
have you guys here I know you're excited
yeah do it I asked the question okay so
I have to ask every time I come to
comic-con walking on the floor is one of
my favorite things to do I have heard a
rumor and you have to tell me if it's
fact or myth
mm-hmm that you may walk the floor as
the comic book version of green arrow
oh that no that was Green Hornet she
that was that was me and uh you know the
Green Hornet only has one of those kind
of half masks and I think that I can um
you know unequivocally state that those
things don't work oh that is a comic
book fantasy everybody was like you're
in a Kendrick why are you in a mask
that's weird
have you have you ever tried or I have I
I ended up have
here for a movie and God five years ago
and was having to do an interview and
notes I was like they want to have like
and something to do yeah you know those
lazy journalists yeah yeah do an
activity
no no but basically so that I decided
the activity you know like the thing we
should do is he I got the cheapest
Burton Ernie
Sesame Street costumes and he was Bert
and I was Ernie and we walked the
comic-con floor and you get did what
happened and it did not happen to you
that's the first year well I wanna in a
way well ironically yeah um I ended up
taking more pictures as Ernie then I've
ever taken as myself my whole life so I
just kept like yeah well I don't know
why like um Ernie like now that that
secret is out are there people who like
took a photo with Burton Ernie who does
are like sure that wasn't Tim really
cool yeah totally
it's the best I mean that's like when uh
what's the name data from Breaking Bad
he wore a mask of himself and walk
that's word you're like really yeah lady
recently with ice John boyega was
walking around
joshan but I want to ask you guys like
for this feels distracting work water
we're gonna get in there yeah I'm jumpin
we're competitive really friends don't
do it Kerry
dress can we just address the giant
Jenga in the room like a fan Jenga the
fan Jenga engine so we won the fan Jenga
here at the spring fashion box
these these are cooler than regulation
blah okay okay no cheat here cuz I'm
just wondering if the paint is gonna you
know affect the it might okay I just
have to wait and see if I lose that's
why I've been taking a look it's the
paint there's a little like dryer you
things where there's something else I
can blame that's not a that's like
that's very familiar well before we get
to I promise we'll get to it because you
talked about working with each other you
always assume everybody knows everybody
in this space like how long have you
guys known each other literally just met
just today that's it it's going great
you guys are really good at let's play
the game no weed you know especially
with a movie like this you're all your
voice work is usually done isolated
you're by yourself but because it was a
musical and some idiot gave me the job
of doing all the music gotcha
that was kind of the that was the
collaborating that we did get to do was
you know I sang and he goes do it better
that was our collaboration is that gonna
be of a movie yeah I do I'm sorry a good
blooper troll behind the sound board
branch just going do it better copy just
good this time right starts with a soft
and then ends with a yell yeah yeah yeah
well star is born
sorry are you ready yeah I know you're
obviously you guys have good chemistry
working together but this is a little
competition that we want to do
whoever wins Jenga obviously there's
gonna be a prize but for fan Jenga each
block has a question on it okay so when
you take the cart of the block out that
question is for you so hopefully you get
good ones so Anna you're gonna go up
first all right oh she's been looking at
that piece oh I don't know what's gonna
go down we're gonna go then take it out
there quick oh my head quick cut one
down oh man oh it's moving oh wow wait
do any other words so now you're two now
you've gone too far
no it's going down Wow fresh man I doubt
it hmm when you were a child what did
you want to be when you grew up I want
to be like what did you want to be when
you grew up with the longest version of
that question when you were a child what
did you imagine you had to inherit
there was a period where I wanted to be
a doctor and I actually just found I
kind of forgot about it and I found
recently a photo of me like doing a
check-up on my dad
where I've got the stethoscope and like
the you know I guess they must have
gotten me like a bib or something and I
had the big uh you know hospital mask
but it's basically covering my entire
face so I'm just going like this with
the stethoscope
I've never good good I was not a very
good child doctor so there's probably
better I would be ruining lives I really
do I'm appropriate looking shirt on
right now looks like oh yeah
banana is my actual instruction yeah I
made it fruit um all right every time
when I go yeah do it
uh-huh oh you got it got a good one mmm
oh man all right just moved a little bit
what would you do if you had more time
in the day what would I do would you do
I'd sleep in yeah I have a 15 month old
oh yeah okay I would sleep in yeah what
was the last time you get to sleep in I
don't remember yeah I'm asleep right now
hasn't been here literally looking at
you all right all right Justin you're up
okay so oh yeah there you go
dang you guys I feel like mine's gonna
be the hard one oh no we've got some
paint sticking right see we've got some
paints tickets yeah almost there
geez ah whoo you did it we go yeah does
this for me or both you guys okay
yes both Mustang what is the cooler part
of their job not the coolest yeah it
really don't go all the way yeah what's
the most moderately cool I'm trying to
find a world in which that says coolest
like maybe the head writing but it says
cooler what does a cooler part so you
answer and if you think yours is cooler
cooler answer uh the cooler
my cooler than Justin you know is that
when I'm on a really cold shoot you know
when you're like out in the middle of
the you know whatever um little Jen Jeff
what are you going literal yeah and then
you like warm up a little bit yeah the
coolest thing is that I get those you
know those hand warmers they give you um
but I can put them all around my bra so
so warm bonus yeah this guy warm boobies
Justin what's cooler than that I don't
know what could possibly be cooler than
warm
yeah all right all right Tiffany all
right you go do it come on I think I got
a good one
yeah there you go oh man see ya oh come
on don't be scared oh okay all right
well done oh wow oh this one's gonna be
for both of you do it we could make
things awkward
who is the funniest person you've ever
worked with oh that's a good question
yeah or if you want who's the funnier
yeah more the funner
yeah the funner uh you know who's a
really fun guy like a frustratingly
funny guy um who is in this movie and
I've worked with him before is James
Corden he is a super cool dude awesome
dude and like the first couple times I
met him I was like if you were a girl I
would he would feel super threatened
Justin opsin you worked with many many
people read times Saturday live also
mm-hmm who would you pick well um no one
gets me to break like like the old fouls
yeah Fallon on SNL and he's even funnier
uncensored off of television so I'm
gonna go with my lover Jimmy all right
who's up now all right yeah
oh sure sure I started I'm so confident
I know I thought I would surely get one
of you guys out I liked that you went
though the first move was bold look at
what could I just say yes if the whole
thing had fallen over you would have
lost your like if I knock it over she
just thought of something no I meant
that I thought that I would like set it
up so that surely by like block four and
be done what was your favorite movie as
a kid
oh so many um when I was I remember
loving um Buffy the Vampire Slayer the I
love the TV show but I also loved the
movie I have no sense of history you
were a brown tie great movie um Newsies
hocus-pocus
um Newsies a Christian by the guy with
the eye patch was my crown and it was
great and then when I was 12 somebody
showed me the women for the first time
and that's been my favorite movies in
Wow women of all the awesome Justin on
Golden Pond know uh uh uh et the
extraterrestrial Ferris Bueller's Day
Off um also Goonies mmm real quick
better still a star do any sequel should
they make one would you like to see
Joanie see um I feel like there's a
bunch of movies in the last like decade
that you're like there's no way that
should ever have a sequel or remake and
then you see in your leg that was pretty
good yeah
so I don't know I don't know I guess it
whose are they
no it's right now the rumors naca but
it's always been out there for so long
it just depends on who's directing yeah
yeah okay doesn't it always yeah all
right well we are just about to wrap it
up but Christian I want you to try and
pull one last one last one
really bill were in no way I got the
high score at seat boner Tommy good Oh
almost boy oh all right
can I urge to do like a Peterson Pete
Rouse I think I'm gonna ask no I can't
ask I'll ask on how many pushups can you
do prove it Oh
I mean how long have you got I'm just
gonna go down here where the cameras
can't see is I guess control gods are
gonna love it I was about to do a really
solid lazy piece of comedy where I said
a thousand we did a little time line a
little bit comes back up and looked all
tired you're they're keeping me honest I
can do one girl pushup okay we don't
have to prove it like it already one
girl pushup - so all right well I wanted
to because you guys are such good sports
thank you Anna
Oh Jess thank you thanks what is it what
is it I want it
Oh give it to me it's something cooler
than we could have given you before it
might be Oh what is it
flip it over Wow there you go and you
guys all watching thank you so much for
hanging out with us make sure you check
out everything going on and coming on
from Fandango Aaron they're gonna be
going to the movies a lot we're gonna be
here talking to everybody at comic-con
now I'll just I'm gonna destroy this in
do one last one
whoa watch out I really was ready to go
for like this oh sorry oh did you watch
dinosaurs still existed aw it's too bad
we didn't get to that one
you